are you like this at all ever commit a
crime
you know in the past just getting
started you ever
and this is where my assistant would
jump in because she has a sordid
criminal past
and has been very open about it but she
shoplifted like crazy uh
no i wasn't into that because of the
wrath of god and all that
exactly scared of the wrath of god
um no i didn't want to sin
growing up
but um i would say if i ever committed
crimes it was mostly vandalism that was
my thing or
yeah but i will and i did some identity
theft you know but that runs in my
family
going back to the 14th century
yeah i am antonio no you're not
okay i try
well i'll just say you know
well i learned a lot from my family but
i'll just say that but um
but you know what kind of vandalism
would you do well you know i grew up in
delaware in wilmington delaware and um
there were a lot of it's a really
interesting place to grow up because
you're kind of there's a there's this
presence of the dupont era of things
always and so there's always
like i would never vandalize
things that were
i think like you know new or nice it was
always like
going to the old
you know dupont experimental station or
the mill factory the abandoned mill you
know mill or whatever there aren't
bricks in the windows and right um we
would grow up around a lot of those like
new
suburban
developments you know where they were
always building the new like cookie
cutter houses or whatever and i would go
in in there and i would write i would
take nails and i would write messages to
the construction workers like you'll die
you know
nails
to make to make it seem like
a ghost are you lying them out or are
you hammering them in no no i would i
would just
arrange them in
letters nails and letters that's not
vandalism per se it's just that threat
okay that's just like threatening public
safety you get arrested for that
trespassing
i think you get trespassing but what
about the guy who
is like owes the mob money and and then
goes to work that day
and says well it'll probably be okay and
they'll never find you
and uh i'm hiding out as a construction
worker in delaware yeah and then gets to
work and it says you'll die written out
in nails i really get it and then he
just says i'm just gonna go into the
woods and kill myself and then later on
you find the skull
and it all comes around yes that was
that's what i wanted
that is literally what i wanted you're a
criminal mastermind yeah you're a genius
yeah but no shoplifting is for little
[ __ ]
thank you thank you very much i'm just
wish sona was here right now we'll have
to tell her she adores you by the way
she loves you and she will freak out
that you pretty much called her whole
life okay up until
31
the life of her 31 she was really she
was shoplifting
late into her life yeah constantly i
don't know about that but i do i support
you know stealing from the
the man the man yeah
me too yeah although i think i am the
man yeah
i just realized that yeah